good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight as american forces were
pulling out of afghanistan this summer
mark milley the chairman of the joint
chiefs of staff announced a new and
highly
innovative intelligence partnership the
pentagon millie explained would begin
sharing classified information with the
taliban yes the taliban the bearded
religious extremists in man pajamas that
for 21 years we've been told pose a
major threat to us in the united states
but no longer they're our partners now
the biden administration mili explained
was even open to coordinating with the
taliban on counter-terrorism strikes
against our new enemy a shadowy group
that may or may not actually exist
called isis k
we don't know what the future of the
taliban is
but i can tell you
from personal experience
that this is a ruthless group from the
past and whether or not they change
remains to be seen
and as far as our dealings with them at
that airfield or in the past year or so
in war you do what you must
in order to reduce risk to mission and
force not what you necessarily want to
do
any possibility of coordination against
isis k with him
do you think
it's possible
because when you're fighting isis k
no holds are barred
so the first of millie's coordinated
attacks against isis k arrived three
weeks ago it was august 29th that was
just days after 13 american servicemen
were killed in a bombing at the kabul
airport a date you remember well
at the time even democrats are pointing
out the obvious joe biden is senile and
totally incompetent so the
administration at that moment
desperately needed something to prove
they are not senile and incompetent they
are instead decisive and strong
and what better way to do that than to
kill people
so that day the u.s military bombed a
white toyota in a residential complex
not far from the kabul airport the white
house touted that strike as a
demonstration of our over-the-horizon
military capabilities in afghanistan
particularly against isis k
now mark milley who's pretty young to be
senile but often seems like it strongly
agreed this was a good thing
at this point we think that the
procedures were correctly followed i
know it's a righteous strike
did we say good thing we meant righteous
that was a righteous strike and everyone
in washington agreed one unnamed u.s
defense official described the attack to
our jennifer griffin this way quote
multiple suicide bombers inside the
vehicle struck by u.s drone today in
kabul significant explosives in the
vehicle led to secondary explosions
bombers belonged to isis k and they were
on route to kabul airport end quote
so it was perfect
all the bad people were dead
all those isis k operatives
and virtually every news organization in
the country parroted this account they
were grateful to give poor old joe biden
credit for something the washington post
assigned five reporters to the story and
they dug deep they concluded they
concluded that biden's drone attack had
hit quote an islamic state target
on television where there's mostly no
reporting at all they just read the
paper and repeat it not a single person
seemed very skeptical of this
our ability to demonstrate effectively
that we can strike such targets once the
intelligence cues them up we can strike
them from outside afghan borders which
is a critical element of the biden plan
once we withdraw so this over the
horizon capability was demonstrated i
thought it was effective you call this
strike remarkable this is a realization
of what president biden calls the over
the horizon strategy the military event
today is so much more than just a single
drone strike it is a projection of power
it is a message from the united states
government that even though we're
leaving we're not done with
counterterrorism operations even though
we're going to have to do this as they
say over the horizon from remote
locations and it's going to be far more
challenging we can still do it
so keep in mind
every single one of the people you just
saw speaking
knew nothing
literally nothing about this drone
strike other than what they read on
twitter they were totally ignorant and
that did not prevent them as it never
does from trying to sound totally
authoritative
that's our news coverage
soon however a few people started to ask
the obvious questions for example who
exactly had the us military killed
when asked the defense department
wouldn't say oh that might have been a
tip
dod also would show no proof of those
secondary explosions the explosions that
proved the vehicle was being driven by
isis-k suicide bombers
instead mark mille just assured the
country those secondary explosions were
real they happened we know and the rest
of us need to take his word for it
that was exactly the line from the
pentagon's top flack known liar john
kirby
two quick questions
if i may
on the strike against the vehicle
do you you
the the central command talked about
secondary explosions i think and that
but to actually have visual evidence
that there were secondary explosions are
you convinced
that there were because that seems to be
one of the potential contributing
factors
to civilian casualties so do you
are you
are you certain there were secondary
explosions yes can you i just have a
follow-up on a different part of this
can you say how you're sure
no
ooh
liar not the first time not the 50th
time are you sure they were secondary
explosions
yes
how do you know for sure i'm not going
to tell you
and he never did neither john kirby nor
anyone else at the pentagon ever
corrected that story
but the new york times did to their rare
credit
more than a week ago the new york times
ran a piece revealing with video
evidence that the buy administration's
drones did not actually kill anyone from
isis k whoever they are assuming they
exist
the drone killed a civilian aid worker
and a car full of kids
there were no bombs in the toyota they
had bottles of water which are very
different from bombs in that they don't
explode even secondarily
finally this afternoon the bite
administration was forced to stop lying
so here's general kenneth mackenzie the
head of u.s central command
having thoroughly reviewed the findings
of the investigation and the supporting
analysis by interagency partners i am
now convinced that as many as 10
civilians including up to seven children
were tragically killed in that strike
moreover we now assess that it is
unlikely that the vehicle and those who
died were associated with isis k or were
a direct threat to u.s forces
okay
after consulting with our inter-agency
partners all of whom get the new york
times delivered at home we are admitting
that we lied to you for weeks about what
we actually did it was not isis k there
were no suicide bombers there were no
secondary explosions it was kids and
water bottles
in his remarks today most tellingly
general mackenzie declined to announce
any consequences for this either for the
killing of children or for the lying
about it for weeks
now why is that
we think we know
back on september 1st mark milley
explained that the drone strike of
august 29th wasn't out of the ordinary
in fact it followed the very same
procedures as every other drone strike
over the last 20 years in afghanistan
we had very good intelligence
that isis k was preparing
a specific type vehicle at a specific
type location
we monitored that through various means
and
all of the engagement criteria were
being met we went through the same level
of rigor that we've done for years
and we took a strike
oh we had very good intelligence luckily
the same kind of intelligence that led
us to believe that german-educated
saudis would never fly airplanes into
the world trade centers or the pentagon
or a field in pennsylvania
the intelligence that told us the berlin
wall wasn't about to fall the
intelligence that told us it was fine to
give up bagram air base because kabul
was safe
the government would stand that
intelligence
so the drone strike of august 29th that
killed a car full of children underwent
and we're quoting the same level of
rigor that we have done for years well
that's not very reassuring is it but you
will not find a more revealing statement
about our pentagon leaders it explains
why no one has been punished for this
disaster
if you fire mark milley for killing a
bunch of kids unintentionally and then
lying about it maybe the accountability
chain will start
maybe they want to fire whoever left
hundreds of american citizens behind in
afghanistan and lied about that
so you can't start firing people just
because they're terrible at their jobs
obviously
so you can't fire anyone that's the rule
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else